and despite what some commentators want
you to believe Labour's plan for brexit
is clear and simple it's time to take a
decision out of the hands of politicians
and trust the people to decide it won't
be a rerun of 2016
this time the choice will be between
leaving with a sensible deal or
remaining in the EU that is the policy
it really isn't very complicated so an
incoming Labour government will first
secure a sensible deal that will take no
longer than three months because the
deal will be based on terms that we've
already discussed with the EU including
a new customs union a closed single
market relationship and absolute
guarantees of rights and protections
it's a deal that will protect
manufacturing industry in this country
and respect the precious Good Friday
peace agreement in Northern Ireland
which was one of the great achievements
of the Labour Party
[Applause]
and then we'll put that deal to a public
vote so if you want to leave the EU
without trashing our economy or selling
out of our NHS you'll be able to vote
for it if you want to remain in the EU
you'll be able to vote for that either
way only a Labour government will put
the final decision in your hands because
this has involved a whole country from
the start it can't now be left to
politicians to finally get this sorted
and move forward we need the people to
sign on the dotted line and we will
immediately carry out your decision so
Britain can get beyond brexit Boyce
Johnson staked his reputation on leaving
the EU on the 31st of October do-or-die
ditches were mentioned many things were
mentioned and lots of Churchillian
language was used no ifs no buts he said
so the failure to do so I'm sorry can
only be his Boris Johnson's failure the
irony is for all his boasting Johnson's
sellout deals still won't get brexit
done it will lead to years of continuing
negotiations and uncertainty whereas
Labour's plan will sort it quickly
because whatever the final decision we
won't be ripping up our main trading
relationship the EU negotiator Michel
Barnier
has said an EU deal on Johnson's term
would take three years maybe more of
further negotiations Johnson's sellout
deal with Trump could take even longer
imagine the time it would take to fill
all those pork barrels in the US Senate
and all the other places just imagine it
think about it so a vote for
conservatives is a vote for yet more
drawn-out bogged down negotiations more
broken promises and more distractions
from the vital
use facing us that care and Laura have
spoken about this morning like making
sure people have decent wages secure
homes and absolutely crucially in this
election beyond all others a habitable
sustainable planet for our children and
our grandchildren
[Applause]
a green light a green light for Boris
Johnson's sellout Trump deal would just
be the start of years more brexit chaos
and division
people sometimes accuse me of trying to
talk to both sides at once in the brexit
debate so people who voted leave and
people who voted remain do you know what
they're dead right
they're absolutely dead right why would
I only want to talk to half the country
I don't want to live in half a country
anyone seeking to become Prime Minister
must talk to and listen to the whole
country labor stand is not just for the
52 percent or the 48 percent but for the
99 percent we bring people together it's
labor labor that's determined to bring
our divided country together you can't
do that if your whole political strategy
is to turn one side of the brexit debate
against the other the Tories are
offering an extreme and damaging form of
brexit while the Liberal Democrats want
to ignore the results of the 2016
referendum and revoke article 50 the
brexit crisis does need to be resolved
but it must be done democratically
because walk down any Street in Britain
and you'll find people who voted to
leave and people who voted to remain
whatever our differences may be on this
one issue at the end of the day we have
so much else in common
I'd like to put it like this if you're
living here in Harlow you may vote it to
me you've got bills to pay
you've got rising debts your work may be
insecure your wages insufficient and you
can barely stretch the money to meet the
needs of you and your family you're up
against it if you're living in New York
for example it's more likely you vote it
remain you've got bills to pay
you've got rising debts your work is
insecure and your wages there
the stretch to meet your family's needs
you're up against it but between a leave
voter in Harlow and a remain voter in
York you're not against each other
Labour's plan
[Applause]
Labour's plan will get brexit sorted